EVELYN GOSNELL:
OK, show of hands.
Who in the room is working
on a product or an app that
is designed to improve people's
lives in some way or another?
Hands are up in the room.
If your hand is not up, get out.
Just kidding.
So if that is true,
if we're looking
to help people improve
their lives in some way,
then the key question
that we need to answer
is how do we survive
over the long term?
How do we increase
long-term engagement
so that we can better
do this over time?
And that's what I'm going
to be talking about today,
but I want to start
with a story--
something that happened to me
recently on a trip to Montreal
that I think everyone
can relate to.
It speaks to a problem that
everyone in this room has.
The story I want to tell
is about the travel portion
on a trip to Montreal.
Montreal is a wonderful city.
I highly recommend
it, but that's not
what I want to talk about.
I want to tell you about
the trip going there.
I happened to check a bag.
I hate doing this.
It's super inefficient.
But I did so because
it was a longer trip.
Checked my bag, take the flight.
The flight's delayed.
By the time we land,
everyone is just--
we just want our bags.
We just want to
get out of there,
and it's taking forever
for the bags to come out.
What happens then?
Finally, beep, beep, beep.
We hear the sound that
we all want to hear.
The luggage carousel
is starting-- awesome.
So everyone crowds around.
I'm sure you're
familiar with the scene.
Everyone crowds around
as close as they possibly
can to the luggage carousel.
Now, there's only so
much room in front
of that luggage carousel.
Not everyone can be
at the very front.
So if you're one of those
poor souls in the back,
you're sort of
crouching and looking
behind, in between heads,
and trying to see where
your luggage is coming out.
Finally, you see it.
And again, you're blocked.
Excuse me, sir.
Sorry, can I get through here?
And you get your luggage,
and you can finally
get out of there--
great.
Now, if we think about
this scenario for a second,
we probably all realize it
would be better if we all
stood back maybe a foot--
a foot and a half.
That way, there'd be enough
room when your luggage actually
comes out.
That's the real time
you need to come up.
There's plenty of space.
You can get your luggage.
You don't bruise and
bump anyone on the way.
And the solution works
better for everyone.
But, individually, if
you think of this idea,
or if I think of this idea,
and you just want to say,
I'm going to stand back.
What's going to happen?
You're just going to be
that one chump in the back.
Everyone's going to
crowd in front of you,
and you're not going be
able to see your luggage.
And we're kind of
at the same place.
But some of you probably
have seen airports
where their luggage
carousels are designed
a little bit differently.
They have a white line painted.
Raise your hand if you've
seen this somewhere
around the world.
There's a white line painted.
And what happens
then is everyone
stands back a little bit, and
the whole system works better.
And so this is
what I want to talk
about today is how do we create
this white line for ourselves
in our space?
And what space are we in?
The attention economy.
Every single one in this room,
whether you like it or not,
you're battling for
people's attention.
I would say to the
death, but maybe that's
a little over-dramatic.
So we really all
have to be fighting
for people's attention, and
there's a limited amount
of time in the day.
There's a limited amount of
attention that they have,
and we're all battling each
other for this attention.
And how are we doing that?
What's the main currency
in the attention economy?
It's notifications--
that is the tool
that we're using in this
fight for people's attention.
And why are we turning?
Why are we relying so
heavily on notifications?
Because we learn very early on--
a lovely gentleman named
BF Skinner taught us
about the importance of
random reinforcement.
So we did these
experiments with rats
where you set it up
so that the rat would
come up and push a lever.
And when they did that,
food would come out--
awesome.
What he learned though
is that if you set up
the lever differently so
that food doesn't come out
every time but only
some of the time,
what happens then to the rat?
Exactly, I see someone
going like this.
That's exactly what happened.
So the rat pushes
the lever much more
frequently when it's set up to
give food not all of the time
but only some of the time.
And I'm sorry to say that we--
whether we like it or not--
are much more like rats
than we might want to admit.
Think of a Facebook
notification.
You don't know what
it's going to be.
It could be a like.
It could be a comment.
If it's a comment, I
got to go figure out
is it a good comment?
Is it a bad comment?
Or it could just be oh,
it's your random Uncle
Tom that you never talked
to's birthday today.
There's this whole range of
what this notification could be,
and it's the fact
of not knowing--
is it going to be a good one?
Is it going to be bad one?
Is going to be a neutral one?
That is what creates this
really, really strong pull
of notifications.
Now, we know this.
The challenge though for us is
that notifications can be very,
very problematic in many ways.
These are unintended
consequences.
I'm not saying that anyone
is meaningfully doing this,
but there are a lot of areas.
And errors is the first one
as my slide already tells you.
So this is really
well researched.
So, for example,
in terms of errors,
there's lots of studies that
bring people in and then
divide them into two groups--
so random assignment.
Literally, if it
was this room, we
would take you half
here-- you'd be
in group A. You half here--
you would be in Group B. We'd
put you in different
rooms, but then we
would give you the same task.
Usually, it's a quantitative
sort of math test--
math assignment that you do.
And let's pick Group
A as the lucky group.
You guys, while you're
doing your math problem,
we're going to ping
you with notifications
as you're doing it.
Group B-- sorry, no
notifications for you.
And what happens in
how successfully people
do this math problem?
Who thinks they're equal?
Awesome, everyone's
paying attention.
Who thinks that group
A makes more errors?
You guys are a
really smart group.
This is true.
So Group A makes many
more errors, actually.
And I'm very struck by this.
Depending on the study,
it's not like 5%, 10%.
It's actually about
double the error rate--
twice as many errors.
So I just want to let
that sink in for a second
and especially think about the
fact that we use this term--
our users.
We talk about our
users, and that's
what we say in the industry.
But I want to pause
on this and say
our users are real
people, of course.
Our users are our doctors.
They are our teachers.
They're the engineers who
are building our bridges.
Do we want to be setting up a
system where we're potentially
doubling the error rate
of what they're doing?
Probably not.
The second area where
notifications can be
problematic is with time cost.
So specifically,
like switching costs.
So you're doing one thing.
You get a notification.
You look at that.
You open the app.
You kind of get sucked down that
rabbit hole for a little while,
and you come back to
what you were doing.
So Gloria Mark has
shown us that it
takes us an average
of 23 minutes
to refocus on our
original task--
and that's from
one interruption.
Multiply that out
through the day,
and we think about
what is this total cost
on human productivity?
What are all the
amazing things we
could be doing if we weren't
incurring these switching
costs?
And related to this--
there's also measurable
stress and frustration.
So we can measure
this psychologically,
and that comes from this idea
of, oh, I've got distracted.
And now I have to spend
this mental energy--
emotional energy refocusing
on what I'm doing.
So what does all of this mean?
Does this mean that
notifications are all bad?
Probably not.
I also actually do want
to touch on this, the fact
that we can see--
I nerded it out for a second and
told you all about the studies
because I'm a behavioral
scientist, and I do that.
But we can also, even
if I didn't tell you
about the studies, you
probably already know this
from looking at the media.
The headlines that
we see out there--
"Six Ways to Overcome
Smartphone Addiction," "10
Tricks for Checking
Your Phone Less."
I mean these are a dime a dozen.
We see these all the time.
We see this trend of millennials
turning off their social media
entirely or going on
month-long social media breaks.
We also even see it's kind of
funny and sad at the same time
that there are these
things called digital detox
retreats where people
literally pay money
to have their phones
taken away from them.
This isn't Silicon Valley.
Is there any shock on that?
So we see this in the media.
We see this in the
app space even we.
See more and more apps try to
help people deal with the fact
that there's this sort
of love-hate relationship
with their phones.
How can I better
understand how many minutes
I'm spending on my phone?
How can I not let it
have such a strong pull
on my time and my productivity?
I was struck--
recently, I discovered
this app called Snowball.
This app specifically
turns off--
kind of blocks
annoying notifications.
That's its whole reason for
being and function in life.
That's just one.
I'm sure there will be
many more in this space.
So what is this telling us?
There's, again, as
I was saying, this
is kind of hinting at the fact
that there's a problem here.
And it's for us to think
about how can we resolve this?
I would argue that as
designers of the system,
we have some moral
responsibility here.
We could also just take
that argument aside though.
We could just say
forget about that.
That's nice and all.
That's how it is.
We don't care.
You could take that
argument aside.
Here's the real kicker--
over-relying on notifications
is bad for developers,
and that's what I want
to talk about too.
So this is a study that
looked at the top reasons
that people uninstall apps.
Uninstalled apps is pretty
much the worst case scenario
for any of us.
That's the last thing that
we want people to be doing.
This is a study in which people
were given a lot of reasons
that they could answer.
They could pick more
than one, so the totals
do add up to more than 100 here.
But what is the
top reason given?
Annoying notifications.
This is the last thing that
we want to have happening.
Combine that with
the fact, when we
think about our model
in this industry,
how sustainable is this?
This is an industry where we
know we have very high user
acquisition costs.
We're spending lots of
money on the front end
to bring in new users,
new users, new users.
And yet what happens is,
after the first month,
we're retaining 36% of them.
The second month, 25, the
third month down to 20%.
So another way to look
at this is across all
industries-- this is
an average, by the way,
of all industries
within the app space.
80% of all app users are
churning within 90 days.
This is insane.
And the question is, how
is this sustainable for us?
We're going to run out of users.
We better repopulate
the Earth really,
really quickly because
we're going to run out
of users to tap in this model.
So the bigger question
is, what do we do?
Are we on this ship headed
for self-destruction,
or are there things
that we can do?
I actually want to
talk about three things
that we can do starting
with the most obvious--
stopping the madness, stopping
the attention-grabbing madness.
So I think we can actually
all agree that sending--
this is a real scenario--
sending three notifications
within one hour
about the exact same video that
wasn't going to go anywhere.
This video wasn't
going to go anywhere
if I wasn't going to watch
it right that second.
This is probably not
being a good citizen.
I think we can all
agree about that.
Now, as I said, I'm
not trying to say
that all notifications are bad.
The question here
is what boundaries?
What would that look
like if we said,
this is how we want to
function in this space.
This is a better way
of thinking about this?
What would that look like?
That would be things like--
let's click forward to the next
slide--
aligning with our
users' intentions.
So another show of hands--
how many people in the room
have some kind of subscription,
membership, something like
that you have been meaning
to cancel, or you
probably should cancel,
but you haven't gotten
around to doing it yet?
Lots of hands going
up in the room.
What's up with you guys?
If you want to do that,
why aren't you doing it?
We have this a lot.
We have this with health.
I mean to eat healthier.
I mean to exercise
more, but I don't.
These are challenges.
In psychology, this is called
the action-intention gap,
and our opportunity
is to say, how can we
bring these two together?
Imagine a world where we
can help people achieve
what they're trying to
achieve, from healthier
eating to working out more
to being more productive
or whatever it is again--
whichever space you're in.
And this would mean that
if you're Headspace--
I believe Headspace is
somewhere in the room.
If you're Headspace, let's
say that someone downloads
your app, meditates for
the first three days,
but on the fourth
day, they drop off.
Sending a notification
to ping that user
to come back and
meditate today is fully
aligned with that
user's intentions.
So this would be a good example
of sending a notification.
Another example-- this
probably sounds like heresy,
but we should not be forcing
the users to open the app when
we get a notification.
This is a health
app, obviously--
Mango Health.
It says it's time
to take care of you.
You have one health reminder.
Oh, and so then
you open the app,
and you discover that
it tells you to drink
water, which is very helpful.
Great, I should hydrate.
I should drink water.
Contrast though with Argus
that tells you immediately,
directly-- drink water.
This is a much more respectful
way of engaging with our users.
Another example--
a positive example.
If your Waze, you know that
someone takes 280 regularly.
Hey, by the way, 280's
about to shut down--
very helpful, timely information
for that particular user.
United Airlines-- you're
walking to one gate.
Hey, by the way, your gate
changed to another one.
You might want to
be going that way--
helpful information.
Clarity Money-- hey,
you're overspending
for how you usually spend.
You might want to
taper that down--
helpful timely information
relevant to me.
The last example I'm
going to give you
is from an app called ShapeUp.
It's in the health and
weight management space.
It's an app that I'm working
on, and we know from research
that stepping on a scale
daily, especially when it's
done in the morning, is
correlated with weight loss.
So this is sort of our
baseline fact that we know.
So my challenge is
to say, OK, great.
Now that I know this, and these
people want to lose weight.
How do I help them do that?
I need to get them
to step on the scale.
How do I do that?
Notification-- but how
do I do it in a way
that we're maybe not going to
be dependent on the notification
forever?
I ask them to think of a
habit that they already have--
something that's already
happening in the morning.
Do you want to do this
before you brush your teeth?
After you eat breakfast?
Before you do your morning yoga?
So they're choosing which habit
that they want to pair it with.
So we give them a
list of these things.
We ask them what time
do they usually do this.
And so you're giving
the user choice,
and you're helping them
build positive habits.
So that was talking
about notifications,
some quick examples.
I could talk all day about this,
but some quick examples of some
dos and don'ts.
The second piece
beyond notifications
is about aligning our metrics
with our users' goals.
So, for example, if you
are Trello, ultimately,
what is your user trying to do?
They're trying to
complete projects.
get stuff done.
If you are an online
dating app, which
I believe there are
many in the room,
then people are trying
to find a relationship.
That's what they're
trying to do ultimately.
And if you are LinkedIn,
who's over there,
then people are trying to
find a job that they love.
There's probably a
lot of other things
that they're doing as well.
But ultimately, you have to
boil it down to the top thing
that our users are trying to
achieve, these are the things.
They do not care.
They are not
looking and thinking
about number of logins,
number of swipes,
number of LinkedIn
connections we have.
These are different metrics.
And so the question
is what can we do
to align better with our users?
The other part that's
challenging here
is our over-reliance
on short-term metrics.
So I imagine that many of you--
let's say we have a
dashboard in our office.
It's is really big dashboard.
And really big at the top,
we have all of these metrics,
but the two that we
focus on the most--
anyone want to shout them out?
What are they?
Daily active users,
number of sessions, people
are completing.
These are two that I
see time and time again.
And if we think about
this is in our office.
Everyday we come
in, we focus on,
how do I change
these two numbers?
What's the obvious answer?
Notifications.
I can ping with
notifications right now,
and I will move the needle
on those two things for sure.
But the challenge is that when
we're sending a notification,
two things are
actually happening.
One, you're getting the short
blip in engagement right now,
but you're also getting
long-term deterioration.
But we're not seeing that.
We're not looking at that
with such an intense focus
that we have on these
short-term measures.
And I'm not saying that
we shouldn't measure
these short-term things.
I'm saying that we should
create a better balance.
We should focus more on these
longer-term measures-- customer
lifetime value.
I know that many of you in
the room are working on this
or have put together metrics
to do this and kudos to you.
It is much more challenging.
Part of the reason we rely so
heavily on short-term measures
is because it's way
easier to calculate.
You just see it.
You build a little report.
It's there.
Customer lifetime value is
a lot harder to calculate.
Aligning with our
users' ultimate goals
is a lot harder to do, but
it's the right thing to do.
One more piece in terms of
driving long-term engagement
is about increasing trust.
Again, a lot of research
on how to do this.
I will just say briefly
think about any relationship
that you have in your life--
your spouse.
It could be romantic.
It doesn't have to be romantic.
It could be your friendships,
work colleagues--
think about any of
these relationships.
Now, if you only ever
in these relationships
acted in your own best
interest, how long do
you think these
relationships would last?
Not very long if you only
ever acted for yourself.
Now, what makes us
think that this would
be any different in our world?
Imagine a world
where you're Lyft.
This is a mock-up.
This is not real.
Imagine a world where you're
Lyft, and you ping drivers.
Hey, it might be a good time for
you to stop driving right now.
What would we see?
Remember our dashboard?
We would actually see
that number go down
a little bit as some of the
drivers would sign off--
the drivers that we pinged
with this notification.
Active users go down.
But think about the long-term
effect on that driver instead
of someone who is--
I'm not suggesting
that Lyft does this--
but instead of a
model where someone's
like always more minutes, drive,
more, more, more, more, more
versus hey, I care about you.
You've driven probably
enough right now,
and there's not that much
demand anyway in where you are.
Think about how
that person feels.
And so this is just one
example, and then you
can come up with
your own as well.
So what is all of this about?
What I'm trying to
say here is that it's
our opportunity-- our
time to band together
to create our own code of ethics
when it comes to this attention
economy.
This is going to be really hard.
I'm not saying it's easy at all.
But this is the future.
Luckily for us, we don't
have to start from scratch.
People have dealt
with this before.
Let's think of organic food.
Imagine the time--
think back if you can--
when before organic
food labels existed.
So you're the
organic food farmer,
and you want to create
better product that
is healthier for
people, that isn't
polluting the
environment with who
knows what kind of chemicals.
You want to do this.
And so you're
making your grapes,
and you're very proud of your
grapes, and they're awesome.
And they go on the
shelf, and they're
competing with those
other grapes that
have pesticides on them.
And what's the difference?
The only difference at
that point is price,
and you're going to lose that
battle because, at that point,
the consumer has no
understanding-- no idea.
Well, why would I pay more for?
That's all I can see is
these grapes costs more.
And yet, with the label,
this became a signifier--
a symbol of the fact
that these grapes--
this product-- was made with
a different set of standards,
with a different set of norms.
It's in a different category.
So I think this is a really nice
example for us to think about.
Can we create something
similar to that?
The second example I want to
give you is also from food,
but it's from the UK.
So the British government,
like our government as well,
actually, realized
that hey, we have
a problem with our population.
Obesity numbers are
really way too high.
People are very unhealthy.
How do we fix this?
And so one of the
things that they
did is they turned to the
food manufacturers and said,
guess what?
We have two choices here.
One, we will regulate you.
We will come up with
a set of standards
that you're going
to have to follow.
This process is going to be
very expensive, very laborious,
and because we are
an outside function,
we might not necessarily come
up with the right answers.
Sorry, can we go back?
So that was option A--
we will regulate you.
Second option, you guys
regulate yourselves.
What did the British
food manufacturers do?
They said, absolutely,
we will do that.
They banded together.
They created standards
for sugar content
and all kinds of details
on how the products
were able to be made--
fat content, et cetera.
They lowered all of these--
so across the board.
And this was effort for them.
There was cost involved.
Any one of them couldn't
have done it individually.
The whole reason why this worked
is that they did it together.
But then everyone won because
consumers, in the end,
ended up with products that
were a lot less sugary.
So this is, again, our
opportunity to create something
for ourselves.
There's examples of this.
These are just two
that I've given.
But ultimately, it's time for
us to create our own white line
to design a system that
works better for everyone.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]